[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mai treffe
meine lieben freunde zum ende der
letzten episode haben wir diese dumme
schüssel hier geeignet im ozean das
result wieder ich habe auf jeden fall
geangelt in der letzten episode zum
ersten mal so richtig und habe diese
schüssel hier nur geangelt deswegen
brauche ich eigentlich nicht aber dann
nämlich zeit wieder mit was wir auf
jeden fall auch unter die letzte episode
in die kommentare geschrieben wurde war
das hier
luca ist es niemals schaffen dich
innerhalb von nur zwei folgen auf das
ende vorzubereiten deswegen meine lieben
freunde habe ich für heute ich mir
gedacht suchen wir einfach schon mal das
end portal
ich weiß die begeisterung hält sich in
grenzen die sache ist allerdings dass
ich mich wirklich schon ein bisschen
auch vorbereiten möchte wir sind in
folge 89 in zehn folgen ist die letzte
folge von daher werde ich zuallererst
mir erstmal hier den lohnstopp
rausnehmen und den berauschten auch
mitnehmen denn das wird mir auch und in
die kommentare geschrieben ihr wisst ja
ich bin immer sehr aktiv in den
kommentaren also wenn auch ihr tipps und
ratschläge oder vorschläge habt schreibt
sie auch gern und parteien mir wurde
mich geschrieben
nimm dir einfach in geistlichen also
einen villagers und der handel mit ihm
dann bekommst du die ränder perlen und
ich glaube ich habe ja sogar nur wie
viel in japan hatte ich irgendwie fünf
oder sechs oder so in einer kiste schon
einmal ganz kurz nach ich habe nur sechs
sender perlen und wenn ich diese 6n ab
er einmal ganz kurz ich kann euch mal
zeigen hier mit lohnstopp rein packe
dann an ich kann sogar einen lohnstopp
dem ok da muss ich gar nicht wenn die
hölle das wollte ich auch erst machen
dann habe ich auf jeden fall solche ende
augen und diese ende augen kann ich
okay ich habe neue rezepte
ich kann jetzt auf jeden fall soll ende
august in die luft schmeißen
danke du mich auch darüber informiert in
die richtung jetzt auf jeden fall unser
stronghold also dass
höhlen die
sag jetzt nicht dies weg
oder
so dass schon jedes mal wenn wir eine
werfen dies bot jetzt allerdings meine
lieben freunde sind dass sie die ende
augen das sind quasi ender perlen so ein
bisschen auf steroiden wie können die
einfach liegende richtung schmeißen oder
irgendwo hinschmeißen und die zeigen uns
wo das end portal ist also das portal wo
wir schlussendlich in diesem projekt hin
wollen und ich brauche eine rege ende
perlen und damit ich nicht die ganze
zeit endermann töten muss ja wirklich
sehr stark sind euch ja schon den ein
oder anderen toten in diesem projekt mit
zu verzeichnen habe ich mir auf jeden
fall gedacht mir geschrieben erholt in
den geistlichen da kann es mit ihm
traden klar kann ich jetzt auf meine
insel da hinten gehen da vorne da die
villa insel allerdings haben die alle
schon im beruf die sind ja teilweise
schon fischer bibliothekar und schmid
und keine ahnung was da habe ich mir
gedacht fahren wir einfach mal wieder in
unserer über wasser dorf und geben dort
einem dem beruf geistlichen und eine
ganz kurze time lab
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde da sind wir
jetzt auch schon angekommen hier in
unserem villiger dorf auf dem wasser
wenn auch hier blöde löcher überall im
fußboden na ja die sind wir auf jeden
fall
aber nichts hören ich nicht schwimmen
können die sache ist das theoretisch der
hier hat keinen beruf aber das wird mit
dem strich heraus zu holen von der schau
ich mal hier hinten der auch kein beruf
dann können wir ihnen auf jeden fall zu
einem geistlichen verwandeln und ihr
seht doch schon ich hab mir acta und
gold mitgenommen habe ich mich ein
bisschen informiert in minecraft vigier
und habe mir gedacht mensch so muss ich
mit dem handeln also a
das ging fix ok perfekt da kommt auch
schon an und wir bekommen redstone
brauche ich zwar nicht weil sie müssen
ja auch nur ein bisschen hoch traden von
daher hier nochmal ein bisschen ich
nehme jetzt mal meine smaragd glocke und
verwandelt die kurzes maracle wir haben
zweieinhalb sechs markt also wenn das
nicht klappen sollte jetzt gleich dann
weiß ich auch nicht mehr wir haben es
auf jeden fall und er müsste sich genau
jetzt schon verwandeln und müsste dann
von der stufe lehrling über wandern
jetzt ist ein lehrling ok perfekt und
jetzt nämlich schon das goldangebot und
ich weiß nicht wohin wir meinen ganzen
gold deswegen jetzt einfach mal ganz
kurz ein bisschen gold hier traden da
kriechen pass marke wieder zurücknehme
mein gott wieder raus und er verwandelt
sich jetzt als nächstes wieder nicht zu
einem lehrling sondern zum gesellen
glaube ich hoffe ich mal und es ist ein
geselle perfekt das heißt wir können und
was können wir uns trennen sondern ein
bisschen glos dauern können kommen sie
kaufen ein bisschen kloster unternehmen
wir mal noch ein bisschen redstone mit
würde ich sagen davon hat er jetzt
allerdings mal am start von daher müssen
wir wirklich bloß bonn bleiben also
können wir uns hier noch ein bisschen
kloster haben das jetzt am start und
jetzt müsste er schon meister werden
glaube ich und dementsprechend auch
schon mit uns die ender perlen nun
können wir schauen mal und er hat die
ender perlen am start perfekt und jetzt
sogar ein verringertes angebot mit nur
vier stück und ich benötige auch ich
habe sechs ich benötige zwölf stück also
benötige ich insgesamt diese anfang an
perlen ich hoffe ihnen noch ein paar
mehr wir haben so vieles mag ich weiß
nicht wohin damit und ich glaube lieber
zu viel als zu wenig haben von daher
kann ich jetzt hier die ganzen nochmal
weiter kräften und mir daraus jetzt
zwölf stück mache und ein bisschen ender
perlen behalte ich einfach mal fürst
ende weil es natürlich auch sein kann
dass der erfahrungs flächen verkauft
auch
[Musik]
in ab herren sind jetzt aber ausverkauft
ach guck mal wie viel kriegen jetzt
dadurch kommen neun stück abgekauft wir
haben 35 mill und ich bin jetzt level
das war der dümmste kauft den ich je
gemacht habe
[Musik]
du bist wie sonnen verkäufer irgendwie
der türkei am strand mit einem viel zu
langen sakko der ihm dann so 10 rolex
verkauft zehn jahre garantie 10 jahre
garantie
ja dann gebt mir die erfahrung zurück
aber gut meine lieben freunde ich kann
auf jeden fall meinen braucht an die
wieder mitnehmen den geistlichen lasse
ich einfach mal hier ich nehme mir jetzt
nicht mit auf meine innere dessen viel
zu großer akt mit dem boot und so weiter
und so fort die sache ist allerdings wie
könnte ja auch jemand hessen mit dem
ende augen meine insel ist da hinten
falls ihr euch die teilmärkte wisst ihr
dass das heißt das auge müsste auch so
in die richtung fliegen ich schmeiße
diesmal hoch
[Musik]
ach so es
gibt wasser mehrere and portale weil es
nur sinn gemacht hätte dass die ender
perle bzw das ende auge in diese
richtung geflogen wären wir müssen uns
jetzt auf jeden fall ein bisschen wir
einen freund euch noch eine ganz kurze
tipps wie ich es hoffentlich vom
sonnenuntergang nach hause schaffen
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde da sind wir auch
schon wieder an unserer insel hier
angekommen guck mal habe ich letztes mal
schon provisorischen brot gepackt ich
sehe da vorne auch direkt schon wieder
eine bi ich weiß nicht ob ich vom boot
aus schießen kann ja kann ich auf jeden
fall so sagt er ist tot jetzt einmal
ganz kurz die parken und hoffen dass sie
nicht noch weitere monster sind ich will
jetzt nicht das noch in den letzten
folgen jemals in die luft fliegt der
leuchtturm ist auf jeden fall angegangen
ich habe in der time capsule das habt
ihr wahrscheinlich gesehen kurz geguckt
ob ich nicht irgendwie ein bett mit
dabei haben leute 2 kassiert
und leute 2 6 4
[Musik]
wir haben es auf jeden fall hinter uns
meine lieben freunde die nacht ist
vorbei ich wusste dass wieder irgendwas
passieren wird aber ich bin noch ganz
ehrlich wir hatten lange keine krieg bei
mir hier am start und es wäre natürlich
schön gewesen wenn er da hinten kreuzer
einzige gewesen wäre aber wir haben
natürlich noch einen zweiten gibt er
direkt vor unserer bude war hier wieder
alles kaputt gegangen perfekt kann ich
gleich noch zwei wächst hier
der ist halt kein platz mehr drauf hier
natürlich wieder die grobe erde drauf
und die beiden margeriten und jetzt
probiere ich es trotzdem mal mit dem
schild dass ich vielleicht irgendwie
hinkriege wir hatten ja
ist er gestorben kuh
hielt für dann schreibe ich jetzt
einfach mal tun noch mit dazu und an
darunter
schildkröte von daher meine lieben
freunde eine schweigeminute
die verstorbenen tiere auf unserer insel
das hier vorne bei euch mal auch eben
kurz wieder neue auf ich weiß nicht mehr
genau wie das alles war wo genau erde
war wo gras war wo was anderes war dann
allerdings kam erstmal buchstein ich es
ein bisschen dafür benutzten füllt den
untergrund hier einfach erde doch was
ich glaube so etwas auch aus hier vorne
waren natürlich noch die laterne drauf
und werden hier auch noch den
bilderrahmen wo eine fackel drin war und
eine bruchstein stufe glaube ich also
sodann eine fackel hier und da eine
stufe irgendwie hier rein so das hatten
wir auch noch der wolke noch irgendwas
mal geschrieben mit irgendwas mann
ambros reinpacken soll dann sieht es
noch mal besser aus lassen wir jetzt
erstmal so erstmal hier warten bis das
gras darüber wachsen wir das auf jeden
fall wieder aufgebaut und jetzt können
wir uns dann tatsächlich auch darum
kümmern dass wir meine lieben freunde
das ende suchen ich sortiere hier gerade
noch mal ein bisschen meine items packte
den ganzen rats online.de nicht neu
bekommen habe es markt benötige ich auch
erstmal nicht mehr wir nehmen die ender
perlen mit wir nehmen uns selbst
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen bruchstein
mit lohn staub lasse ich erst mal noch
hier den rest in benötige ich erstmal
nicht mehr meinen bestand partie auch
erst mal hier rein bzw kann ich auch
gleich wieder direkt nach oben räumen
glos dann brauche ich auch erstmal nicht
was er einmal immer gut aber zwei stücke
seiner zu viel essen ist wichtig und die
ende augen natürlich um es gleich zu
finden und dann nehme ich mir jetzt auch
noch mal hat die bruchsteine habe ich
ein schild habe ich nehme mir auch noch
mal das totem der unsterblichkeit mit
und pack das über in die linke hand
anstatt ein schild dass wenn ich sterbe
dass ich dort dann auf jeden fall ja
wiedergeboren werde und ich nehme mir
auch ein bett mit das wort nimmt in die
kommentare geschrieben da wird nämlich
gesagt luca wenn du aus dem song hold
raus gehst bz wenn du das stationäre
bevor du uns ende gehst jetzt auf jeden
fall ein bett vor das portal so dass du
dort einfach wieder response wenn du
getötet wir es nicht dann wieder dahin
laufen musst du deine ganzen items dies
bauen und zwei transporter als auch
danke dir dafür den kommentar generell
danke für eure ganzen tipps und hinweise
und wir
meine lieben freunde werden uns jetzt
zum ende bewegen ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich werde mich heute noch nicht richtig
in der stronghold rein wagen denn allein
der ort um zu dem and port zu kommen ist
schon furcht einflößend genug ist schon
gefährlich genug und da habe ich mir
gedacht wir fahren dorthin es mit der
anscheinend irgendwo dahinten sein wir
fahren dorthin und wenn ich dort bin ich
ein bisschen holz mitnehmen doch niemals
einfach mal hier noch ein halbes deck
eichenstämme mit und ich werde auch
meine crafting table mitnehmen so dass
ich mir sachen kräften kann was ich von
sagen wollte war meine lieben freunde
ich werde dort heute
ich weiß genau dass balu will dass ich
ihn mitnehmen weil und ich sind auf
jeden fall auf dem weg in richtung ende
beziehungsweise weiß ich gar nicht ob
die richtung ist also ich würde sagen
dass wir noch mal ganz kurz die vorne
halten und ich meine appelle hoch und
dann schauen ob ich wirklich über den
ozean drüberfahren muss also war ganz
kurzen ende auge nehmen hoch schmeißen
und es geht in die richtung meiner
lieben freunde ganz schnell das wegen
natürlich wieder auf sein wenn ihr fragt
euch wahrscheinlich lukas sammelst du
dir alle wieder auf du hast zwölf
stücken ist doch riesig ich muss die in
das portal reinstecken also in dem and
poor tal sind so rahmen und da müssen
diese ende augen rein und das ist 3 x 3
x 3 x 3 also insgesamt 43 also zwölf
stück deswegen sollten diese zwölf stück
auf jeden fall ausreichen sei denn ich
verliere eine dann wenn es blöd aber ich
bin guten mutes dass wir das hinkriegen
unser nächster stopp ist diese kleine
insel davon seien dann spreche ich
nochmal eine hoch dann guckt man in
welche richtung wir müssen ob es
vielleicht nach links oder nach rechts
und was sie auch wohin sagen wollte war
ich werde das heutige video bin ich
schon mal ganz ehrlich muss ich euch
auch schon sagen das heutige video werde
ich beenden wenn ich an dem ort bin wo
ich mich runter graben muss in der
stronghold reinen das möchte in der
nächsten episode machen da möchte ich
eine komplett eigene episode machen denn
ich benötige da wirklich noch mal eure
tipps ob es irgendwelche genauen
vorgehensweisen gibt okay wir müssen
wirklich über das wasser ob irgendwelche
guten vorgehensweisen gibt wie man da
irgendwie vorgehen soll ob man irgendwie
sich so und so bewegen sollte ob es da
und da irgendwelche tipps gibt im sinne
von hey wenn an der wand zwei
cobblestone blöcke sind dann da heißt es
dahinter ist das portal von daher könnte
mir jetzt schon mal gerne in die
kommentare schreiben was ich beachten
muss wenn ich in der folge die über
online geht in das frommhold reingehe
also in diese cent gefängnis da unten
allerdings leben wir jetzt gerade im
hier und jetzt und müssen uns erst mal
darauf konzentrieren dass wir dieses
ende überhaupt finden das kann ja sein
dass das noch extrem weit entfernt ist
deswegen balloon erstmal hier raus bzw
ich brauche einfach ganz großartig
hängen wieder festigt auch man immer
ganz kurz mein brötchen hier ab dass wir
perfekt weiterlaufen können sollte das
nicht direkt wieder mit und ab nach oben
balu kommt natürlich auch mit ich hoffe
er schafft es bis an land zu kommen ist
immer ein bisschen lava asche unterwegs
perfekte teleportiert sich einfach von
daher jetzt mal wieder eine perle
geschmissen sie geht immer noch in diese
richtung also es ist wirklich so dass
unser stronghold anscheinend sich in
unserer region hier vorne befindet die
hatten ja auch schon interessante
erfahrungen gemacht hier vorne auf dem
eis und dann mit balu war als sich auch
noch auf dem boot wie wir nach oben
gefahren sind das war echt der funny ich
weiß es nicht genau ich glaube sie sind
diese richtung hergeflogen etwa deswegen
laufen weil sie erst mal ein bisschen
weiterhin und schmerzen hier auf dem
hügel die nächste ender perle bzw ende
august wechsel nicht einmal so ein
bisschen weiter in diese richtung
freunde also in den wald oben rein war
auch wieder klar dass es spannungs mäßig
genau jetzt in richtung nacht sich zu
eignet und die sonne so langsam
untergeht was hätte auch anders sein
sollen von daher hier gekonnt
hochspringen balu es noch immer
es war nur hinter mir wurde
balogh ist hinter mir perfekt weiter
geht's freunde da hinten haben wir
dieses bikes nähe das sind bäume
schmeißt man hier noch mal ganz kurz ein
es geht immer noch weiter in den wald
rein ich weiß nicht wie weit ich hier
noch laufen muss bitte lande nicht auf
einem baum ok perfekt und weiter in den
wald rein die nacht bricht an ich bin
gespannt ob wir es heute überhaupt
finden werden ich weiß nicht mehr wie
weit sonst rollt weg ist ich glaub ich
hab noch nie so richtig in minecraft
projekt von mir überhaupt das ende
besucht aus das waren vielleicht
multiplayer projekt ich weiß es nicht so
genau die sonne geht auf jeden fall so
langsam unter ich bin froh dass ich im
bett mitgenommen habe wir haben
[Musik]
ich brauche jetzt nicht
ist das jetzt hier
also eigentlich war das unterirdisch
oder okay es geht wirklich noch weiter
in die richtung also das war es noch
nicht
[Musik]
hier sind auf jeden fall auch freunde
von ballonen ihr habt gerade in der luft
gesehen freunde dass die ender perle
hier nicht geblockt ist und wieder
runter zu mir gegangen sondern sie ist
kaputt gegangen das heißt an diesem ort
meine lieben freunde befindet sich das
ende des projekts minecraft mit luca wir
müssen hier auf jeden fall runter gehen
allerdings würde ich an der stelle die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca jetzt
erst mal beenden es hat unfassbar viel
spaß macht die heutige episode weil wir
wieder viele neue sachen entdeckt haben
die sonne geht gerade unter ich las
baganz prozess sitzen und schlafe auch
so dass wir in der nächsten folge dann
direkt in einen neuen tag starten können
es ist wundervoll ich mit dem polarlicht
an und so ich hatte das selber immer zur
mitte des projekts eingestellt dass wir
hier so geile lichter am himmel haben
aber gut meine lieben freunde wir sehen
uns genau hier übermorgen wieder ich
hoffe ihr seid wieder mit dabei über
morgen 20 uhr und dann werden wir uns
runter graben zum ende es übermorgen
tschüssi
[Musik]